ora tutti ragazzi ovviamente questo non
video sono la vj oggi siamo sul mio
divano e questo non è un porno giuro
siamo su fallout ragazzi che un
videogame figo melo lo sto giocando in
questi giorni faccio che giocarlo mentre
registro perché la cosa mi figlia un
sacco nel caso vi steste chiedendo
perché sono nudo questa è la spiegazione
oggi che a stupenda di fallout che con
il completo da reietto che sarebbe
questo qui ciò addosso o 6 7 e 15 mentre
con questo scassinatore braccio sinistro
indurito o 87 15 quindi di più di prima
ed è così sono a nudo o solo uno
spallaccio come cazzo fa essere più
efficace questo che quello di prima ecco
questo è vabbè avete capito terai nudi
godetevi la vostra ultima ora
ma conti sta parlando che cazzo ma
[ __ ] la caf bravo cane o dio è
morto un cane
e morto il cane ragazze non è vivo il
cane di superman bravo cane vieni qua se
casomai vieni quartini qua la star dove
vai
mi stai evitando la voga scambia cosa
scambio è un cane mi dispiace se
scambiamo qualcosa è un cane è
interessatissima quello che stai dicendo
zio credimi pianoforte dovevi che devi
poter ai nudi da queste parti chiamiamo
la tua pettinatura straordinaria
conviene la mia pettinatura zio non so
se te ne sei accorto ma c'è una maschera
che cazzo di capelli veri john perché
aggiunge john travolta voi voglio vedere
come mi taglio i capelli con la maschera
son curioso
insomma curioso essere tolta ricavi per
quale motivo dovrei scegliere il taglio
calvizie incipiente cos'è è illegale in
45 stati statali e questo e vas di far
cry che cazzo c'entra insegnante di
matematica solo quello di matematica
accessi capelli quello di fisica c'era
diversa ragazzi se diamo un dito di
capelli cerasa tissimo come cazzo fa un
parrucchiere a farli diventare così non
ne avevo da che non ne avevo lì sono
diventato così play me li faccio così
ragazzi appena esco esatto street a
quanto è utile è stato molto utile amico
mio hai visto che figo il nuovo taglio e
cioè non sono un gran figo alle
takahashi e di takashi ma che fa schifo
ma no che sia un robot giapponesi
raccontami una barzelletta
sono giapponese cosa chiede a san
gennaro sono vestito non sono più nudo
ma chi è
no non voglio andare a scuola voglio
andare a scuola o scherzando una
verifica e sorprese ragazzi una verifica
solo in quanto grande
io ho ma con chi minchia pensi di
parlare di man man come sono cresciuti
bassi ma non rompere toccamento preso
per un pedofilo o di noi faremo una
verifica piu avanti
ma quando mai è successo a sta cosa
cinque anni di superiori
manco una volta è successo che può fare
ha rinviato la verifica ragazzi spiega
come avete fatto
mi scusi lei perché vi una scuola in
pigiama e senti ron weasley mette almeno
un jeans dio mio santo ciao
salve sono io sono famiglie sono
simpatico ecco lui il mio amico ve lo
presento e socievole sono qui da qualche
parte ce li hai dietro [ __ ] quanto
efficiente su tizio da 1 a 2 mila è che
si fa in groppa re dei cani bravo bravo
e inviti utile alla vita cosa vuole da
me se ti sta sparando lui che cazzo vuoi
da me cos'è ma cos'è una tigre del
bengala
ma che cazzo hanno mica le armi di
ritorno al futuro un calcio nei [ __ ]
un robot serve a molto minister palle
d'acciaio ma forse ma è uno stupro a
star di non vale toglietevi ma non vale
per cos'è certo stuprate un nuovo in
mutande bravi ravi a prendervela comune
col pisello della vostra taglia sto
morendo che cos'è un nuovo passo di
danza dai odio wrestling john cena porca
[ __ ]
sono vivo per miracolo mi chiami salvare
che bush onde culo saltata una mina in
faccia il mio solito culo nei videogames
andiamo cambia il carrello dell'auchan
ragazzo sa dove cazzo è il reparto dei
salumi e ti lamenti
non ho ma continua a star fermo quando
esci dalla porta c'è scritto
commonwealth che sarebbe tutta la
regione come se io uscissi fuori da casa
mia e invece di scrivere milan a
scriversi lombardia
capito [ __ ] che in lombardia mi ha un po
più preciso no chao cosa fai
le pippe involtino dolce mica come
ridotta la tizia non so quanto possa
essere bonos involtino credi camicia di
flanella e jim è la madonna a distanza
di anni si è sempre una gran [ __ ] molti
rifugiati si possono sollevare le cose
mi chiamerà dimenticato visto che noi
siamo amici da tanto tempo ti voglio
fare questo regalo prendi tutto tutto
ragazzi non lo capisco c'è qualcuno mi
deve dare una spiegazione ho trovato
un'arma piccola questa cosa qua bello ma
non ha neanche piccolo così posso
portarne la scuola durante le
interrogazioni ragazzi avete presente le
zanzare che ci sono durante l'estate
ecco a me una volta è successo di
trovarne una
ecco sono questo non si schiaccia
neanche se ci cade sopra big shot esatto
che cazzo oddio scarafaggi radioattivi
sono degli scarafaggi che cazzo ti copri
cosa fa io sono degli stanno fermi poi
sparargli anche così guarda refrigerante
cosa fai
porca [ __ ] schiaccia lo schiacciano
bravissimo come non detto ragazzi perché
voi cosa vuoi da me la granata era fan
cuore dai
io o mio dio chiesto cosa ci facciano ex
sulle scale bravo o finalmente uno che
se la prende con lui ma edizione che non
serva una minchia mi scusi buon signore
non volevo disturbarla mi piace mi piace
a tutti io gli è saltata una gamba mi
sembra di vedere un vecchietto che cerca
di scopare leziosi messo malissimo che
carta il servizio ottimo lavoro a chi
hai fatto tutto tutti a casa ragazzi
concluso più episodio è stata una roba
strana nel senso che mi sono messo
giocare di mio perché ogni tanto gioco
anche roba mia e ho provato a registrare
nel mentre quindi è stata una cosa un po
improvvisata provvedere cosa veniva poi
è stato un esperimento tra virgolette
però sfigati ricordatevi che gli
scarafaggi vanno schiacciati coi piedi
non con le armi
a meno che non siano grossi così però
quella un altro discorso comunqe ragazzi
spero capito vi sia piaciuto è come se
il video più visto da certo momento è un
mi piace anche a pagina di facebook e
come noi video tolta nella descrizione
ci sia verso i dischi amici vediamolo
prossimo visto ragazzi